dulces
se suele pensar que el celibato es algo
exclusivo de los sacerdotes y religiosos
de la iglesia católica que nos
comprometemos a vivir la perfecta y
total continencia por el reino de los
cielos es decir el no mantener
relaciones sexuales
hoy quiero hablarte del celibato como
una dimensión natural positiva y
conveniente para cualquier persona que
desea ser feliz sin importar su religión
o su condición comenzando por algunos de
ustedes aquí presentes que ya mantienen
una relación más o menos cerrada de
pareja pues si quieres ser fiel a tu
pareja necesitas aprender a hacerse
libre para el resto del mundo
de lo contrario quien no pueda será
infiel y sabemos por diferentes estudios
también por un sentido común que las
personas que padecen infidelidad sufren
lesiones en su alto valor ansiedad
depresión pérdida del sentido de la
propia existencia
y es algo que afecta a una considerable
parte de la población como recogieron
investigadores de la unam en 2007 en una
muestra de 1200 adultos el 36% alguna
vez fueron infieles y el 26% encontró en
alguna ocasión a su pareja en algún
comportamiento de infidelidad
el amor sexual erótico entre adultos en
un marco de amor de respeto puede ser
maravilloso pero cuando se busca fuera
de ese escenario más allá de estos
límites se puede caer en el acoso o en
el hostigamiento sexual del cual son
víctimas del 40 el 60 por ciento de
mujeres según cifras de la onu y más del
25 por ciento de los hombres pero lo más
duro de este panorama es el abuso sexual
sólo como un dato casi 111 mil personas
figuran como víctimas de delitos en
materia sexual sólo en averiguaciones
previas en cinco años 2.5 víctimas formó
por ahora de lo que llega a instancias
oficiales en tan sólo cinco años sólo de
13 entidades de mexico la mitad del país
eventos que ocurren en escenarios
cercanos como en el propio hogar o en
las escuelas por eso para prevenir la
infidelidad el acoso del hostigamiento y
el abuso necesitamos hablar del valor
positivo del celibato
un profesor que es capaz de mirar a sus
alumnas sin acosarlas sin objetar las
estás siendo célibe con ellas así como
también el padre de familia que sabe
abrazar besar y acariciar a sus hijos
sin caer en el incesto momento pero en
qué momento en quien dijo que eso era
algo opcional
por supuesto que no
silbato es algo natural
o qué pensarías de la madre o el padre
de familia que constantemente tenga que
aguantarse las ganas de tener algo así
con sus hijos
y con quién es si puedes tener
relaciones sexuales es algo lógico saber
ser célibe considera el número de
personas con las que puedas tener
relaciones menos las que no quieran
tener relaciones contigo
y considera el gran número de personas
con las que de hecho puedes mantener una
reelección una ración profunda emocional
de amor y de amistad y si todavía
piensas que celibato es algo extraño o
seguro es algo que tú ya lo vives si
consideras que eres una persona capaz de
dar amor amistad y cariño a tus amigos
vecinos compañeros mascotas o
alienígenas sin llegar a ser algo
directa o indirectamente sexual
el celibato me dice en algunas de las
personas con las que soy coach
espiritual no me cuesta trabajo vivir lo
pensarán con la gente que no es sexy
pero qué pasa que precisamente es el
entrenamiento para saber coexistir con
la belleza del cuerpo humano para
afirmarlo celebrarlo admirar lo sin
convertirlo en un fetiche valorando lo
más por lo que es que por lo que parece
más por su ser que por su poseer eso nos
conviene para ser más libres sobre todo
en un mundo invadido por el marketing
que exhibe el cuerpo humano sólo como un
escaparate o un accesorio para vender
productos cuando merece ser visto como
un santuario y un camino para manifestar
la grandeza de nuestro espíritu y
transformar el universo
el celibato tiene que ver con nuestra
inteligencia sabemos que nos resultan
atractivas las personas cuyo cuerpo
parece más saludable y queremos
apropiarnos de esos genes es lo que la
evolución nos ha enseñado además de esta
ciencia necesitamos la inteligencia
emocional que nos permite integrar lo
que sentimos y vivimos en nuestra
capacidad de relacionarnos humanizando
nuestro trato jefe secretaria cliente
proveedor compañero compañera de trabajo
primo prima amigo amiga pues si algo nos
dijo la canción de josé luís román que
canta yuridia los amigos no se besan en
la boca los amigos no se hacen el amor
al igual que miles de personas yo soy
célibe de tiempo completo me considero
un explorador que busca millones de
formas de amar porque sé que el amor es
infinito más allá de lo que solamente es
erótico y sexual sirviendo y amando a
aquellos que me sea posible
y sé que también en mi iglesia algunas
personas creen que el celibato es un
problema o incluso puede ser la causa de
que haya abusos no será más bien el
celibato parte de la solución pues esta
lista de abusos que pueden ocurrir en
las familias en las escuelas campos
deportivos gimnasios piscinas baños
públicos y un horrendo y lastimoso
etcétera son un síntoma del largo camino
que nos queda como sociedad para
aprender a dar y recibir amor célibe te
imaginas la chispa esta chispa lo que
puede encender la revolución de amor
célibe lograr espacios protegidos libres
del acoso sexual porque tú mereces y
tienes derecho a ser bella a ser guapo
le guste o no le gusta quien sea
y radiar la belleza de tu ser de tu
salud de tu juventud
y lograr erradicar la discriminación de
que si vales o no vales que eres más
hombre o más mujer por las relaciones
sexuales que tengas o no tengas porque
todos necesitamos aprender a amar y ser
amados y esos son los ingredientes de
los días más felices de nuestra vida
necesitamos aprender necesitamos
tú y yo nosotros es elevado en nuestras
vidas
[Música]
todos necesitamos experimentar el abrazo
de una maestra un compañero y un amigo
de alguien que te dice te amo sin que
suene raro sin que sea algo extraño
nutrir nuestras relaciones sanar
nuestras heridas el mundo está sediento
de empatía y conexiones significativas
dejar de hablar de celibato sería
renunciar a una de las muchas banderas
de la libertad y del amor
y quien esté libre de amor
que tire la primera piedra
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]